si la france sort du confinement
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas le premier
pays européen à avoir pris cette
direction
premier pays européen où s'est développé
une épidémie de kovy 19 d'italie se
relève progressivement les mesures
restrictives y sont allégées au fur et à
mesure depuis le 4 mai dernier
pour le moment la réouverture des musées
des commerces de détail et des
bibliothèques est suspendu jusqu'au 18
mai mais bonne nouvelle le premier
ministre giuseppe comptait affirmer que
les italiens pourront passer l'été hors
de chez eux
nous ne serons pas sur le balcon de cet
été et la beauté de l'italie ne restera
pas en quarantaine nous pourrons aller à
la mer à la montagne et profiter de nos
villes et ce serait bien si les italiens
passer leurs vacances en italie même si
cela se ferait différemment avec des
règles et des mises en garde mercredi
dernier l'allemagne a également amorcé
son déconfinement progressif
deux jours plus tard en rhénanie le
canton de cozes feld a décidé de
réinstaurer le confinement
le championnat de football professionnel
allemand reprendra quant à lui dès le
week-end prochain
pour autant la crainte d'une deuxième
vague de contamination est dans tous les
esprits
je pense que nous pouvons dire
aujourd'hui que nous avons la toute
première phase de la pandémie derrière
nous mais nous devons toujours être
conscients que nous sommes encore au
début de la pandémie et que nous avons
encore un long chemin à parcourir pour
faire face au virus
m et mme verreault faut comme en france
certaines régions d'espagne entament
aujourd'hui leur déconfinement c'est le
cas à séville à bilbao où il est
désormais possible de réunir jusqu'à 10
personnes ou encore se déplacer à
l'intérieur des provinces les terrasses
des bars et restaurants rouvrent avec
une capacité réduite
en revanche les habitants de la région
de madrid du nord-est de la catalogne
avec barcelone ou encore l'est de la
région de valence doivent encore
patienter pour sortir librement et le
gouvernement prône la prudence à kingson
trains à partir des loups à ceux qui
entrent dès lundi dont la phase 1
je voudrais vous demander toute votre
prudence et toute votre attention
je tiens à souligner une fois de plus
que le virus n'a pas disparu
il est toujours là à l'affût la lutte
contre l'épidémie se poursuit car elle
n'a pas été stoppée et ne le sera pas
tant que nous n'aurons pas trouvé un
vaccin où on remet thérapeutique
efficace rainero ces dames des jo aux
professionnels et au royaume uni
deuxième pays le plus endeuillé au monde
avec plus de 31000 décès le confinement
a été prolongé jusqu'au 1er juin en
baisse une séance bien que nous ayons
fait des progrès pour satisfaire au
moins certaines des conditions que l'on
s'était donné nous ne les avons pas
toutes remplies et donc non ce n'est pas
le moment de mettre fin au confinement
cette semaine au lieu de cela nous
faisons les premières étapes prudente
pour modifier nos mesures en mai
l'europe sort donc petit à petit de la
crise du coronavirus mais prudence
le retour à la vie normale semble encore
très lointain